KIRSTY BENNETT: And welcome
to the McGovern Institute's
first-ever Story Slam.
I'm Kirsty Bennett,
founder of MITell,
a storytelling program for MIT.
I'll be your moderator
for the next hour or so,
as we hear seven McGovern
storytellers share true stories
on the theme of resilience.
We are thrilled to host this
event as part of the McGovern's
20th anniversary
celebration, and we
are particularly
delighted to have
the institute's co-founder,
Lore Harp McGovern,
in our virtual audience.
Welcome.
I've always been a fan of
the McGovern, even from afar,
so much so that I
brought both of my babies
to have their
brains scanned there
in the name of
scientific research.
They're still only one and
four, but maybe they'll
be brain scientists,
too, one day.
But in working on
tonight's program,
it opened up so much more
of the McGovern to me,
and I know it will for you, too.
Through the power
of these stories,
you're about to discover
the diversity of discipline
at the institute, and really
get to know the scientists that
call it home.
That's right, we are
putting scientists right out
of their comfort zone and asking
them to talk about themselves,
as well as their work.
And to our theme
tonight, resilience,
I think it's fair to say
that everyone watching
this event tonight, wherever
you are in the world,
knows something
about resilience.
It's been quite a year.
So tonight, we're
going to celebrate
that very human strength.
This hour, you will hear
stories of failed experiments,
of crushing setbacks,
of overwhelming doubt.
These seven storytellers
have experienced
and overcome it all.
Tonight, each one will share
a true personal story of grit,
perseverance, and resilience.
We have two judges
for today's slam--
Maddie Sofia, host of
NPR's daily science
podcast Short Wave.
There she is.
And Tina Hesman Saey, a
senior writer at Science News.
Hello, Tina.
Maddie and Tina will
have the difficult task
of selecting a winner
for today's slam
at the end of the hour.
They will judge each
five-minute story
on the following criteria.
One, theme-- how
well does it relate
to the theme of resilience?
Two, clarity-- is the story,
and any scientific concepts
in the story, easy
to understand?
And originality-- is the
story uniquely captivating,
and is it memorable?
The winner will receive a cash
reward, this amazing trophy,
and a giant McGovern swag
bag filled with goodies.
And of course, the
prestige of being
named the winner
of the first ever
McGovern Institute Story Slam.
A few quick housekeeping notes.
This event is being recorded.
If you like what
you hear tonight,
please tag us and help us
spread the word on social media.
And our hashtag is
McGovern Stories.
Without further ado,
let's get started.
Now, to introduce
our storytellers,
I asked them all a question.
And I asked them, if you
could go back in time to March
and stockpile
anything, absolutely
anything, what would it be?
When I asked our
first storyteller,
Ola Ozernov-Palchik,
this question,
she answered post-testing fMRI
data for her study and stock
in Zoom.
Please welcome Ola.
OLA OZERNOV-PALCHIK:
I was nine when
my family made the journey
from the former Soviet Union
to Israel.
We arrived with four overflowing
suitcases and one broken floor
lamp.
Immigrants have to make rational
decisions on which items
to bring on thier journey.
For my family, it
was a floor lamp
that we carried with us through
two countries on our journey
to the promised land.
For my husband's family, it
was two Soviet tennis rackets.
When we left Russia, we left
behind our family, our home,
and our identity, but we had
a lot to look forward to.
My parents were
hopeful to escape
the poverty and anti-Semitism
of the Soviet Union.
My sister and I were
excited about all the things
that the Western world had
to offer, mostly bubblegum.
We settled in a small and
government-furnished apartment,
and I anxiously
awaited for the boxes
we shipped from
Russia to arrive.
My books were in these boxes.
I was an avid reader as
a child, and although we
didn't have much,
I remember always
being very proud of the
wall-to-wall shelves of books
my family had.
The books allowed me to escape
my narrow world of long food
lines for the magnificent
worlds experienced
by the heroes in my books.
Our boxes arrived three
months later, mostly intact,
except for two things that
didn't make the journey--
a folder full of my art
and the box of my books.
As for my art, I
grudgingly accepted
my parents' explanation
that my art was confiscated
by the authorities
because it represented
valuable cultural artifacts
forbidden to leave Russia.
One of these days, I'm sure
I'll find them in the Hermitage.
I was devastated by
the loss of my books.
We were among the early wave
of the mass migration of Soviet
Jews to Israel, and
when we arrived,
there were no Russian language
books to be found anywhere,
and so I was left bookless.
The irony of the Russian
immigrants to Israel
is that, in Russia, we
were never Russians.
We were Jews.
It said so in our
identity cards.
In Israel, however, we
were never Israelis.
We were Russian.
The reality that I will never
truly belong in this new
country became evident to
me within the first few days
in my new school when I arrived
to school wearing a traditional
Russian first-day-of-school
dress with bows in my hair,
just to find everyone
else dressed comfortably
in sweatpants.
I was desperate to belong,
and mastering the language
was my entry ticket.
At first, I had a slow start.
For my first few months
we were in Israel,
my mom paid me $0.05 per
page to motivate me to read
children's picture books.
I went from reading
Around the World
in 80 Days in Russian
to laboriously decoding
Llama Llama Red Pajama in
Hebrew one word at a time.
It was painful and demoralizing,
and I felt like a bird
without wings.
I was ready to pack
up my belongings
and travel back to Russia
in pursuit of my lost art.
But the week before
summer vacation,
the class took a trip
to a local library
to pick out their
summer readings,
and I came across
a book about a boy
in a foster family that was a
part of an eight-book series.
I was immediately sucked in,
and by the end of the summer,
I finished all the books in the
series, and by September 1st,
I was so fluent in Hebrew that
I was exempt from the language
learners program at my school.
Reading was my
anchor and my outlet
through our many moves
over the following years.
Through my very
rough adolescence,
books of existential
philosophers
gave me a grand perspective
on my teenage angst.
In the small and
isolated kibbutz
where I was sent to
escape the bad influences
of my neighborhood, in the
remote military base where
I served for two years, and
in my early days in the US,
when I began attending
community college,
my reading is what helped
me survive, and even thrive.
Reading was everything
to me, and so I
was struck when I
first encountered
a child who couldn't read.
Given my passion for
reading, it's not surprising
that, during my junior
year of college,
I began working at the
Institute for Reading Research.
I evaluated the efficacy
of a curriculum developed
by the institute researchers.
And through this work,
I would regularly
visit schools in wealthy
suburban, inner city,
and immigrant neighborhoods to
administer reading assessments
to children at
regular intervals.
I was struck at the variability
with which children made
progress from month to month.
Some kids could
read effortlessly,
others with a bit
more difficulty,
and then there were
children like Rubin,
who had developmental dyslexia.
Rubin was a bright and
chatty second grader
who in the span of our walk
down the hall from his classroom
to the testing room would not
only update me on his latest
LEGO creations, but also
the most intimate details
of his family's life, like
his Aunt Rachel's divorce.
We would enter the
testing room, and his face
would visibly fall.
Rubin would sit in front of me
every two weeks, frustrated,
with tears welling
up in his eyes,
trying his hardest to read
through a passage word
by word by word, just like
I did so many years ago.
But for him, this wasn't
a fleeting hiccup,
but the beginning of
a lifelong struggle.
This experience
sparked my passion
to unravel the neural mechanisms
of individual differences
in reading development.
In my research here
at McGovern Institute,
we've been discovering
that children
at risk for
developmental dyslexia
show brain alterations often
associated with this disorder
as early as first few
months of kindergarten.
Despite substantial hereditary
and behavioral risk,
however, some children proceed
to develop typical reading
skills, and the research shows
that these children often
recruit alternative
neural pathways
and use different cognitive
strategies for reading.
So I'm interested in figuring
out these mechanisms of risk
and resilience in
reading development
because I believe that
reading is not only
a privilege and an
anchor, as it was
for me, but a basic human right
that all children should enjoy.
Thank you.
KIRSTY BENNETT: Yay to Ola.
Thank you so much for being
our first storyteller.
I love that story, and I
have such a clear image
of the determined little girl
who loves bubblegum and wants
to find a way to read.
Thank you for bringing her
into the room with you tonight.
Our next storyteller
is Jill Crittenden.
And when I asked Jill
what she would stockpile
if she could go back
in time to March,
she answered stock in Zoom.
But, she added, she is
not ready to tell us what
she would do with the profits.
Please welcome Jill.
JILL CRITTENDEN: Thank you.
Perseverance is usually
considered a good thing.
It takes perseverance to learn
skills like riding a bike.
Every time you
fall off, you have
to get back on again and again.
In fact, if you've ever
had dinner with a toddler,
you know that even a simple
behavior like feeding yourself
takes perseverance
and repetition.
After a while,
the whole sequence
of movements required for
whatever task you're doing
seems effortless, and
we just go on autopilot.
But sometimes, that autopilot
is our own worst enemy,
and unconsciously
initiates harmful habits,
like nail-biting or smoking.
In many brain disorders, such
as autism and schizophrenia,
repetitive behaviors
can be severe
and very difficult to disrupt.
People become so stuck doing the
same thing over and over again
that they seem
completely unaware
of the world around them.
A few years ago, I was
studying the biological basis
of these extreme repetitive
behaviors in Ann Graybiel's
lab, and we made a
remarkable discovery
about why they might sometimes
be so hard to disrupt.
That's interesting
in and of itself,
but the resilience
part of my story
is about what happened when we
tried to publish our discovery.
We were doing experiments to
test which neurons in the brain
to disrupt a habit.
For example, if
someone says stop
biting your nails, which neurons
here it and make you stop?
We were using genetically
engineered mice to study this
so that we could
actually control
the activity of
specific brain cells
to figure out which ones
disrupt the autopilot.
To induce the repetitive
behaviors, we used amphetamine.
You might or might not know
that amphetamine causes really
extreme repetitive
behaviors that
are really hard to disrupt,
like skin picking or pacing.
Our big discovery was that these
extreme repetitive behaviors
were not interruptible
like they should be.
The autopilot was
deaf, and could not
be turned off when you were
exposed to amphetamine.
Our discovery suggested
that, in other cases
of pathological repetitive
behaviors, when people
were very engaged and seem to
not even hear the people who
are trying to interrupt
them, in fact,
the habit part of their
brain might not even
be getting the
signal that somebody
is trying to talk to them.
When we were writing up
this exciting discovery
for publication, kaboom, a
Canadian group unexpectedly
published a paper about the
genetically engineered mice
we had used, and they
said that these mice, when
they were trying to
solve a task in a maze,
kept turning the wrong
way over and over again.
Ugh.
What did that mean
about the discovery
we'd made about
repetitive behaviors
using these very same mice?
Our team had an
emergency meeting,
and we figured out how
to edit our manuscript
and incorporate the
Canadian group's
findings into our paper.
And then we sent it to a
top journal, and we waited.
Let me tell you a bit about
the manuscript review process.
It has multiple steps.
The first one is to
interest the journal
editors enough to
send your paper out
for review by other scientists.
We succeeded with that step.
The second hurdle
is peer review,
when experts in your field
critique your manuscript
line by line.
There are often only two
reviewers of your manuscript,
but a third reviewer might
be added as a tiebreaker
if the first two don't
see eye-to-eye, so
reviewer number three
is the term that's
often used to the most
harsh critic of your work.
Finally, our reviews were
back, and we had three of them.
I carefully read through
the requested changes
to our manuscript
line by line, but when
I got to reviewer number
three, my heart sank.
Number three said that
what the Canadian group had
said about the genetically
engineered mice that we'd used
was a deal-breaker,
and that we had
to repeat all of our
experiments with a completely
different method.
This would take
many, many months.
Moreover, a key
member of our team
was just about to move
away to California.
I felt like reviewer
number three
had broken both my
kneecaps, but I found out
I could still stand back
up and go in the lab.
While we set up the new
experimental methods
and looked for a
replacement team member,
we looked more closely
at the behavioral mice
we'd decided to
use, and we found
that their repetitive
behaviors, in fact,
went on much longer
than in normal mice.
And we found that the
genetic mutation in them
actually might be
related to this
in the habit part of the
brain, how gene expression had
changed.
So this was
interesting because it
shows how a genetic
mutation can make
someone more vulnerable to
have these extreme repetitive
behaviors.
We wrote up the story
and we published it
without much trouble.
Eventually, we were able to get
the requested new experiments
done, as well, and we
published our discovery
about how amphetamine can make
the habit-driving autopilot
numb to inputs.
So in the end, we got two
papers out of the rejection
by reviewer number three.
So when you read that
review, be resilient.
Persevere.
Maybe you can make
lemonade out of lemons.
KIRSTY BENNETT: And a
huge congratulations
to our second storyteller.
Thank you so much.
This is a story I love
because it lets us
in on the inside
baseball of science
and the scientific process.
I know that there will be
many in our audience who
understand just how terrifying
reviewer number three can be.
So thank you so much, Jill.
Our next storyteller
is Kristy Johnson.
And when I asked what
she would have stockpiled
if she could go back
in time to March,
she gave an answer very,
very dear to my heart.
She said she would have
stockpiled infinite childcare.
Please welcome Kristy.
KRISTY JOHNSON: You
know that moment
in movies where the
character stares off
into space and the camera
zooms in through their eyeball
and magically flashes up all
the memories, all the moments
in their life that led up to
that one particular moment?
That was me on March 8th, 2012.
I was in Indiana, sitting on
the beige carpet of my parent's
living room.
My best friend's father had
just passed away suddenly,
and I'd flown home with
my nine-month-old son
to be with her.
While I was on the plane, my
son's neurologist had called.
He left a message
saying you need
to come in, which is
never a great thing
to hear from a neurologist.
The month before, we'd
been referred to him
because my son, Felix, had
missed every single milestone.
He wasn't rolling over.
He couldn't sit,
didn't babble, didn't
use his hands for anything, not
to grab a toy or touch my face.
By the time we saw
the neurologist,
he immediately called
for genetic testing.
So while I was at the funeral
for my best friend's father,
my husband was
back in California,
where we were living at the
time, listening to the doctor
tell him that Felix was
missing a handful of genes.
One gene, in particular, was
critical for development,
and he didn't have it.
There were seven known cases
worldwide at that time,
but specific patterns had
already begun to emerge.
All of these children
had absent speech,
meaning no spoken words ever.
They had severe intellectual
disabilities, epilepsy,
autistic traits,
motor challenges.
At that time,
there were no cases
of individuals who could walk.
They struggled to use their
hands and plan movements.
And it would be lifelong.
And that night, as my husband
relayed this information to me
over the phone, as I was
already exhausted and raw
and overwhelmed by the
capriciousness of life
and death, I felt an
extraordinary sensation
of clarity.
That was the moment when
all the pieces of my life
fast forwarded to me sitting
on the beige carpeted corner
of the living room.
Up until that
moment, I had thought
I was going to be
an astrophysicist.
Before getting married
and having Felix,
I'd been on a relatively
straight academic path
in physics.
I'd been a Goldwater scholar.
I had graduated summa cum
laude with honors, minors, math
and astronomy, all
the usual stuff.
I'd gone straight into a PhD
program out of undergrad.
But none of that
mattered anymore.
So instead of returning to
finish my PhD, I stayed home.
In the evenings, I
taught college astronomy
and edited scientific
manuscripts and grants
to pay the bills.
But when Felix was
awake, I was with him.
And in every spare second, I was
reading about autism, genetics,
neuroscience,
anything I could get
my hands on that might help.
I began tinkering with Arduinos,
fabricating toys and tools.
It was clear that, if I wanted
a better world for Felix, more
knowledge, better tools,
deeper understanding,
I was going to have
to build it myself.
Eventually, my husband
finished his PhD,
we moved to Boston
for his postdoc,
and Felix started
at a special school.
For the first time since
that night in Indiana,
I considered going
back to finish my PhD,
except physics wasn't the love
of my life anymore, Felix was.
Alas, not everyone found
that as poetic as I did,
and I was routinely
rejected from every position
that I applied to.
Then, while reading an
Oprah magazine my mother
had left in our bathroom, I
learned about the Media Lab,
and I knew I'd found it, the
academic island of misfit toys.
Finally, I would fit in.
Graduate school has been
this winding, wild ride
across disciplines,
trying to figure out
the fundamentals necessary to
build a whole field of study
around individuals with severe
intellectual disabilities,
non-verbal or minimally
verbal communication,
and multiple diagnoses,
including autism.
I built devices, sensors,
algorithms, ran studies.
Eventually, I found my
way to neuroscience,
and began working with
members of the Gabrieli lab
on a project to study the
neural basis of affinities,
those deep, passionate interests
that individuals with autism,
and indeed all of
us, often have.
Felix's world
revolves around music.
It's the way we
connect with him.
It's the way he
regulates and socializes.
And the greatest way
to make him laugh
is a glissando, like Wile E.
Coyote falling off a cliff.
"Kerr-splat."
So instead of asking how
to minimize this love
or how it interferes with
his life, we lean in.
We ask how these affinities can
enhance or strengthen skills.
My research is based
on what people can do,
how they thrive, not the
ways in which they're
deficient or lacking.
Another project studies
nonverbal and minimally
verbal individuals from
vocalizations, like mm, ah, ah.
These are non-speech
but deeply informative
modes of communication.
We've built an
end-to-end pipeline
to capture these vocalizations
in the wild, machine learning
algorithms to classify
them, and we're
developing a tool that shares
the meaning behind these sounds
in real time to enhance
the communication
between non-verbal
individuals and the world.
We're trying to change the
question from why don't they
speak to how do
they communicate.
Here's the thing.
There is a lot that
Felix can't do.
But there's also so
much that he can.
In life, we often don't get
to choose the path we're on,
but we do get to
choose what we're
going to do on the journey.
KIRSTY BENNETT: Thank
you so much, Kristy,
for that beautiful
story, and thank
you so much for introducing
us all to Felix, and for being
the sort of person who
faces a problem head-on
and with so much love.
Please welcome our next
storyteller, Mahdi Ramadan.
When I asked him what he would
stockpile if he could go back
in time to March,
he said something
that I think we all would love
a little bit more of these days,
Clorox wipes.
Please welcome Mahdi.
MAHDI RAMADAN: Thank you.
My story begins
with my mom, sister,
and I being evacuated by US
Marines from war-torn Lebanon
to Cyprus.
I remember finding a
cotton candy machine
on the battleship we were on,
and just for a fleeting moment,
I could enjoy being a kid.
Not a kid terrified of
what he's just experienced,
not a kid terrified
of what lies ahead.
After five long days, we finally
arrived in the Seattle Airport,
and a strong smell
of coffee welcomed us
to our new home and
our new way of life.
Now, this might seem
like a triumphant moment,
that now we're saved, but
it's not always that simple.
As we made our way home, I
remember a mix of emotion.
We were joyful and relieved,
but at the same time nervous.
Are we going to be OK here?
With sudden change comes
sudden maturity, and even
at a young age of
11 years old, I
realized I had opportunities
here in the United States
I didn't have back in Lebanon.
I was absolutely fascinated
by the brain and mathematics,
and I dreamt that, one day,
I want to go to college
and I want to become
a neuroscientist, just
like my hero, Oliver Sacks.
As we settled into
life in Seattle,
everything seemed bright, but
then one day, our foundation
came crashing down.
My dad had his
second heart attack,
but this time it was different.
This time, he lost his job.
Medical bills piled up.
We actually had to relocate from
our home to government housing
to afford rent.
I felt as if the ground
beneath us began to crumble,
and I started asking
myself, am I going to be OK?
Will I still be able to
attend college one day?
I'm still going to become
a neuroscientist, right?
As the years passed by, my
dream of attending college
became more like a
figment of my imagination.
I started noticing a growing gap
between myself and my friends.
While they, during their
summers, went to summer camps
for robotics, coding, science
and sports, I stayed home.
While they received new
computers and video game
consoles for their
birthdays, I did not.
While they started
touring college campuses
with their families and getting
private tutors to help them
with the SATs and
personal statements,
my family could barely afford
a car to get around with.
At this time, I was nearing the
end of my high school years,
and so I had to face my
reality and make a decision.
Is college still a
possibility for me,
or should I pursue something
more practical and get a job
and support my
family financially?
And I had discussions with
my family about college,
and it was full of
uncertainty, questions like,
even if I get into college,
who is going to pay for it?
What are these scholarships,
and are they a scam?
Why neuroscience?
Maybe I could pick
something easier.
What if this whole college
thing, this whole university,
this whole academia,
science thing
is just not made for
families like us?
A pivotal moment came when
one of our family friends,
Laura, who had known me
since I was two years old,
and knew how bad I wanted
to go to college, basically
forced me to apply for a
high school summer research
internship at the
University of Washington.
I was so sure that I wouldn't
get into the internship.
Why pick me out of all the kids?
But to my surprise,
I got chosen.
The feeling that somebody
out there actually
saw potential in me, even
though, at that time,
I didn't see
potential in myself,
is what inspired me to
actually go to the internship.
Now, on the end of the
first day of my internship,
I thought I had made a
huge, huge, huge mistake.
The kids around me, they
were so smart, so confident.
They already knew how to code.
It's as if they've trained for
this moment their whole life.
I just didn't belong there.
I should go back.
On the second day
of the internship,
I learned I was
placed in a lab that
dealt with a left ventricular
assist device, which
is a system that you implant
for heart failure patients.
And in that moment,
I really thought
about my dad and
his heart problems,
and that intrigued me.
What is this device,
and how could I ever
contribute to this device
and to these people?
And that's what pushed me
to go in the third day.
On the third day, I was
given my first task, which
was to code up a
small piece of code
to simulate the heat properties
of one of the components that
have to go inside
the patient, and we
have to make sure
that it doesn't
burn the tissue of the patient.
I'm terrified.
I've never coded before.
I've never even opened
the program before.
Why did they pick me?
Why not just another
student who should do it?
But at that moment, I
had to stop and think.
What if I don't take
this opportunity?
What would my life look like?
What if I'm forever constrained
by the financial circumstances
that were handed down to me?
But in that moment, I
decided to take control.
And it took me two weeks
to create this little piece
of code, but in those two weeks,
I created that piece of code.
And little did I know that
this little piece of code
would create the coil design
for the component that, selected
out of many in the
lab, would end up
being used for the
first clinical trials
the system underwent.
And not only that, but
it turned out later on
that my coil design was as
close to optimal as it could be.
And this is the first time that
I felt the ground solidify,
and that the first step
I took in this path
wasn't muddy, that
it didn't sink me
and I didn't make
a fool of myself,
that actually this is
a path that I can take,
and that I want to take.
I could go back to
my family and say
that I have a contribution and
impact to make in the world,
and that I can do
it, and that college
might just be the thing for me.
Inspired, I applied and got into
the University of Washington,
took part of ever more
computational pieces of work
and research, anything
from seizure predictions
to models of visual cortex.
And I'm proud to say
that, here at MIT,
I've actually had the privilege
of teaching programming
and how to code to
incoming graduate
students in the department.
And now, as part of
the Jazayeri lab,
I study the computational basis
of counterfactual thinking,
the same sort of cognitive
processes that went on in that
pivotal moment when I
thought, what if I take this
opportunity, but
what if I don't?
And today, I share my
story for those of you
out there who feel like me.
And I want to tell
you that you don't
have to be constrained by the
financial circumstances you
were born in, that
you can follow
the passions of your heart,
and the most important thing
you have is not
money or connections,
but the belief people
have in you and the belief
that you have in yourself.
And I'm here to say to
you that I believe in you.
Thank you.
KIRSTY BENNETT:
Thank you so much,
Madhi, for such a
wonderful journey,
from being on a boat with the
Marines to the Jazlab at MIT.
It is an incredible story.
Thank you so much.
Our final storyteller for
tonight is Heather Kosakowski.
And when I asked
her what she would
stockpile if she could go back
in time to March, she said--
and I [INAUDIBLE]
with her, too-- hugs,
because she so
misses seeing people.
Please welcome Heather.
HEATHER KOSAKOWSKI: Have
you ever experienced hate?
Not the haters gonna
hate kind of hate,
but someone's deep loathing
directed toward you?
When someone hates
you that match,
their face becomes so
distorted with rage,
they are unrecognizable.
Violence is inevitable.
And if you happen to be brave
enough, or stupid enough,
to look into that
person's eyes, well, there
are no words to describe the
intensity of hate-filled eyes.
In that moment, the object
of hatred becomes just that--
an object-- and ceases to exist.
At least, that's
how it felt for me.
My mom had the ability to
need me with one breath
and, in the next, be filled
with such rage and utter hate
that bruises were inevitable
and my life was in peril.
How do you survive the
hatred of your own mother?
Resilience, grit, perseverance.
Those words have
marked my entire life,
and they are not
words I am proud of.
Behind those words
are a lot of pain,
a lot of overcoming,
a lot of surviving,
sexual, physical, and mental
abuse, homeless shelters,
welfare, foster care, the Marine
Corps, systems and structures
that broke me, failure
after failure after failure.
And somehow, for
some unknown reason,
I have still fought, still
persevered, still survived.
My whole life, I only ever
dreamed of two things--
going to college
and having a family.
At the age of 26, I
started taking classes
at the local community college.
A few short months
later, I was pregnant.
I dropped out.
A baby.
Messed up little me was
going to have a baby.
How could someone like me,
that has never been loved, ever
give love?
When she was born, my
sweet little baby girl,
I was filled with
such awe and wonder.
In the maternity ward,
I would carefully
swaddle her, place her in
her bassinet, and just stare.
Her cute little cheeks,
her sweet little nose,
her perfect little eyes, wrapped
in her knitted purple blanket
and matching hat that nurses
came and went every few hours.
One particularly peppy nurse
bounded in, oh my gosh,
she is so sweet, I bet you are
just hugging her and kissing
her all of the time.
Then she took her
vitals and left.
Kissing her?
I can do that?
She was two days old, and it
had never once occurred to me
to kiss my own daughter.
Right then and
there, I tried it.
It felt awkward at first,
this learning to love thing,
but also right.
I started to learn all the
mom things-- baby baths
and bouncing and burping
and diapers and swaddles.
One day, when she was
just about six weeks old,
she cried and cried and
cried, and there was nothing,
literally nothing I could do.
As she cried, I made all
sorts of promises to her.
I told her it was OK, Mommy
was there, she was safe.
I told her that I love her.
And in that moment,
I knew it was true.
A few months later,
the afternoon sunlight
was streaming
through the window.
With smashed avocado
and sweet potato
stains all over the
counter, I looked down
into this sweet baby girl's
eyes, into my daughter's eyes,
and I realized, I want
the world for her.
I want her to know that she
can do anything she wants.
Looking at her, I realized that,
if I want her to truly believe
she can accomplish her dreams,
I would have to accomplish mine.
And so I set out on a
journey of self-discovery,
of academic inquiry.
I came back to the question
that has haunted me
since childhood--
what drives people to hate?
A few years later,
I found the paper
that transformed my thinking.
I had already learned
that hate happens
when we fail to see
the humanity in others,
but this paper explained
the neural mechanisms
that enable us to actually
see someone else's pain.
Then it occurred
to me, if I want
to understand what happens when
things go wrong, when people
learn to hate, I have to
start at the beginning,
before we learn to hate.
I have to start with babies.
Have you ever looked
into the eyes of a baby?
Oh my gosh.
If you haven't,
you need to try it.
There is nothing more
heavenly in this world.
Babies give and receive love
at any moment with any human.
Not yet closed off to the
realities of this harsh world,
human babies have a way
of innocently connecting
with anyone that's willing,
and saying, I am here with you,
and I see you as you
are here with me.
It is powerful.
So I set out to
better understand
babies, the place where we all
begin, before we learn to hate,
but are capable of immense love.
How do babies see the world?
My pursuit to understand
how infant brains support
their minds is a new
dream, one I wouldn't
have even dare dreamed that
fateful day in my kitchen
so many years ago.
It has been hard.
So hard.
I have cried a lot.
I have lost a lot.
But I have also shown my
daughter that not only can she
achieve her dreams,
she can have dreams
beyond her wildest imagination.
You all, I am a
PhD student at MIT.
Do you know how unheard
of it is for a foster kid
to get a bachelors
degree, let alone a PhD?
And yet, here I am, a
foster kid PhD candidate
at MIT doing the
kind of research
that only a handful of people in
the world have even attempted.
Over the last few years, I
have held, comforted, swaddled,
and looked into the eyes and
brains of over 100 babies.
With every ounce
of my being, I want
to know what is happening
in their mind right now.
And with each baby that I
meet, I stare into their eyes
just as deeply as they look
into mine, and make sure
they know, just like my daughter
did, that I am there with them,
seeing them, as they see me.
KIRSTY BENNETT:
Heather, thank you
so much for such
a beautiful story.
It reminds me to spend
a little bit more
time looking into
my baby's eyes.
And thank you so much for
being so generous in sharing it
with us tonight.
Now, before our judges get
started on figuring out
a winner, I want to give you
a quick recap of everything
that we've heard tonight.
In moving from Russia to Israel,
Ola lost her ability to read,
a moment that shaped her
work as a researcher.
Jill overcame rejection from
that dreaded reviewer number
three.
Kristy told us of a
complete career change
to develop technology
to help her son.
Mahdi overcame incredible
odds and self-doubt
to pursue a dream of coding.
After a promise to her father,
Shannon's circuitous career
led her to the Boyden lab
and who knows where next.
Dipon's late-night
Eureka moment in a lab
cemented his ability as
an independent researcher.
And finally, Heather told us how
she found a new lease on life
after the birth of her daughter.
And now, our judges,
Maddie and Tina,
will be selecting
today's winning story.
They've already ducked into a
magical behind-the-scenes green
room for the next two minutes,
and while they're gone,
you'll be able to see
some photos submitted
by our storytellers
that illustrate
each of our storytellers'
lives and stories.
And while we can't
see you tonight,
we have a chat function open,
and all of our storytellers
can see it.
So while our judges are
deliberating, please let us
know if you're
having a good time
and which stories you loved.
And we'll see you back
here in two minutes.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
Welcome back to our
judges, Maddie and Tina.
That took slightly
longer because they
had a really unenviable
task of having to decide
who would be the winner.
So thank you so much, and I will
hand it over to both of them
for their decision.
MADDIE SOFIA: So that was
ridiculously difficult.
I want to say, first
of all, thank you
to all of our storytellers.
It is not easy to tell
a story, it is not
easy to tell a personal
story, and it is not
easy to tell a story over Zoom.
I will say that for sure.
So we were judging on a
lot of different themes--
we were touching on
themes, originality,
and it was a really
tough decision
because I feel like so
many of our storytellers
today nailed it.
But there was one
storyteller, in particular,
that also did a great
job delivering the story.
There was story structure.
And I'll talk a little
bit more after this,
because I don't want to
keep it from you guys,
but we chose Kristy Johnson
as our winner tonight.
And you know, as a person who
professionally tells science
stories, I have
to say that Kristy
did so many beautiful
things in which there was
an emotional start, there
was a touchpoint for us,
did we all see the
movies where, like, life
flashes before the eyes, right.
And then Kristy did a great
job of doing something
we called signposting,
which is kind
of leaving us little
things along the way
that we're going to find.
Big climactic moment, beautiful
resolution, and the story
was really rounded out.
And so I'm going to turn it
over to Tina to say a little bit
more, but there were some
truly beautiful stories
of resilience
tonight, and I just
want to say thank you again.
It was a very difficult choice,
but Kristy, congratulations.
TINA HESMAN SAEY: Yeah, I would
like to echo what Maddie said.
Every single one of
you told a great story.
You all had turns of
phrase that I envy so much
and would love to have stolen.
And Kristy, what really
sort of touched me most
was how you said that
you're not looking
for the ways these
children are defective,
but the ways in
which they thrive.
And I think that
that is so important,
and that is the
definition of resilience.
So congratulations.
KRISTY JOHNSON: Thanks.
MADDIE SOFIA: I also want to
say for everybody, one thing
that I always tell scientists
that come on our show
is that your passion, your
vulnerability, if you choose
to have that, comes through
more than any amounts
of practice or lack
of jargon or whatever.
And I will say that it's
hard to do that over Zoom,
but Kristy, I feel as though
your emotion, your enthusiasm,
your vulnerability, too,
really pulls people in,
and people want to
pay attention when
you can tell somebody is really
passionate about something.
And so many people
did that today,
but Kristy, I thought you
did a great job of that, too.
So there's all kinds of
practicing and lack of jargon
that you can do, but
really being truly driven
by something important
to you is-- there's
no replacement for that.
So congratulations, Kristy,
and to everybody else, too.
KIRSTY BENNETT: So
congratulations to Kristy,
the winner of the first-ever
McGovern Story Slam.
This very glamorous trophy
is on its way to you,
as well as a giant
McGovern swag bag.
I want to thank our judges,
Maddie Sofia and Tina Hesman
Saey, for their time
tonight, and I really
want to thank all of
you for taking the time
to join us online.
And finally and
most importantly,
I want to thank all
of our storytellers--
Ola, Jill, Kristy, Mahdi,
Shannon, Dipon, and Heather--
for opening up and sharing
so much of themselves with us
tonight.
If you enjoyed the slam, please
visit the McGovern Institute
website to learn more about
future events and other ways
to stay involved.
Thank you, and have
a great evening.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]